robert spencer iran has made it clear
that they will call upon their proxies
in lebanon
syria and gaza to attack israel with
tens of thousands of rockets
should israel attack iran's nuclear
sites
will they call upon those rockets to be
sent
in your opinion and if the attacks do
come what will the world
response be to that new front from the
countries i just mentioned
it is very likely that something like
that will happen in the near future
the extent of it the range of it is
probably not as large
as the iranian regime would have us
believe because after all
it does look as if mossad has already
hit iran's nuclear site several times
in the mysterious explosions and
computer failures and so on
that have taken place at various iranian
nuclear sites
along with the mysterious assassinations
of the iranian nuclear scientists
these are widely believed to have been
israeli
inspired or israeli-directed activity
in defense of itself against a
genocidally hateful regime
and so it would seem to me that if
iran had that kind of rocket power it
would have already unleashed it
but it is certain that there is going to
be more war against israel
and that it is also equally certain
unfortunately that
the world powers led by biden's handlers
are
going to once again call upon israel to
restrain itself
in its own defense and not move to crush
this uh jihad against it entirely but
allow the jihadis
one more breather to gather strength to
fight again another day